you've lived your whole life in a world
that is run by the church and now your
family is getting slaughtered for a
mistake someone else made what would you
do it's only a matter of time before you
get drained of blood I'm going to break
down the mistakes made what you should
do and how to be to Dracula's armies in
Castlevania the people of this city
gather around and watch like as if
they're going to Sunday Night Football
and cheer on while the local City Church
thinks that this woman is a witch and
prepared to burn her alive to save her
soul cause that's totally how it works
she calls out to somebody mysterious in
the air and begs them not to harm these
backwards thinking people they burn her
alive and the skin melts from her body
until her bones crumble to ashes
thinking they've saved this town the
church prepares to celebrate just as a
horrifying creature appears over the
lady's ashes it's Dracula and these
people have just murdered his innocent
wife livid Dracula declares that this
city and the world will now pay the
ultimate price and he tells his demon
Army from hell to kill every human they
see especially members of the church red
and blood the innocent and guilty get
butchered left and right their guts
ripped from their stomachs and
children's heads are removed from their
spine it's a bloodbath and there's
nowhere left to run this is Dracula the
most powerful being in this world and he
has created Technologies centuries ahead
of anyone and this is the reason why
this dumb blonde over here came to
Dracula 20 years ago to learn his ways
and signs and Medicine the Church of
this city has basically rejected all
science and this is the reason why they
killed this lady because they thought
she was a follower of Satan Dracula here
blames Humanity for his wife's death and
at this point as a citizen it's too late
to fix anything we can't call Mulligan
do-over let's try again my bad but
here's how we escape this alive from The
Moment I Saw Dracula appear over his
wife's corpse I am running the radius of
this [__] show is probably going to be
the greatest at the center from where
this priest sat and that means the
further we get away from this location
the less likely we are to encounter
Dracula's earthquakes and Demon Army the
city they are currently in is known as
the city of wallachia a region located
in Europe during the late to Middle Ages
and that means these people don't have
cars to get away very quickly but the
positive thing to note however is that
according to this map this city the city
of greshit is located just south of the
mountains and that means if I'm one of
the citizens inside of the city of
willekia I know there's mountains that
way but just in case I'm going to try to
get a hold of a map of the land before
getting a horse to travel even faster
and while I'm doing this I'm sprinting
down narrow secluded streets far away
from the main routes of the city these
Goblin Demons of Dracula whatever they
are are more likely going to attack the
crowded areas of the city first before
they move outward with my horse and map
until I'm going full on to the city of
Gresham and head into the dense
mountains that will offer better
protection than any City made by man
this will give me time to better figure
out my next move and hopefully find a
way to get out of walekia entirely
meanwhile in a nearby Town Trevor here
takes a break from his job he's a family
member of the world's greatest vampire
Hunter family but he's the only one left
he overhears from these people that
Dracula's armies have begun to take over
the world and it won't be long before
they reach this town at Sunrise he
decides to investigate a city nearby the
one that was attacked just last night by
Dracula's demons the city of Gresham
approaching it he spots terrifying demon
gargoyles outside of the city one
holding a baby in its mouth the sun
rises while the people of this town wake
up to a brutal sight mothers husbands
Sons daughters all dead the town tries
to recover from last night's attack but
everyone is on high alert they know that
by Sundown the same nightmare will begin
all over again because he is so on the
right side of the law Trevor sneaks into
the Fortified City through its sewers
and finds hundreds of corpses and bloody
guts lying everywhere he's never seen
seen a vampire attack so horrifying and
thinks that something else is going on
well holy guacamole this situation has
gotten a whole lot worse this place is
devastated these creatures clearly don't
care about who's innocent or guilty and
means that we're nothing more than food
to them but we do have one thing that
does give us some hope into stopping
this army they are clearly limited by
the fact that they can only come out at
night and that means that Trevor here
has some time to take advantage of the
situation running away in this situation
is totally obvious and respectable but
if I was Trevor I'd use the daytime to
be the best [__] that I could be I
would poke around all the dead corpses
and their places of residence first to
gather supplies such as food and money
which we will need to buy more weapons
and survival gear but then I would
approach places of worship and nobility
in a city such as this specifically for
example the Catholic Church they're
likely to be loaded with coin and from
the looks of things no one else is
clearly a professional vampire hunter
that means our services should be in
serious Demand right now even though I'm
sure they're not happy that I'm a
Belmont I think they'll get over it if
the church says get out of Dodge then
I'm just going to make my way over to
the nobility of this city I'd offer them
my Professional Services and protect
them from The Vampire horde and rather
sneaky value proposition whereby I would
cheat them out of their money for little
work here's how I would demand a large
sum of upfront cash or gold first 40 of
the total amount before stating that I
will go and kill one of the vampire
demons and bring it back to them so they
can examine it whereby I will need
another 15 of the total sum paid to me
totaling 55 of the total fee that after
this I would begin by preparing to take
on the rest of the vampire army or at
least that's what I'll make everybody
else think I'll equip as many people as
I can with the very weapons that I found
from their dead neighbors this will make
people think that I'm in it for the long
haul by delivering one demon to the city
first this will guarantee that my image
as a Fearless Hunter remains intact and
bringing one back in the flesh will
remind the citizens of just how
terrifying these things truly are though
considering they were just attacked last
night it's probably not that hard I
would also make up some BS about
examining their enemy in their position
and how this will give the city and its
people a tactical Advantage should they
ever run into these damage again in the
future truck but however once I get paid
55 of the total amount and they think
I'll be preparing to take on the demon
army with them that's when I'm gonna
bail get out of Dodge and run away just
before nightfall this will ensure that
the city won't be able to catch me since
they'll be too busy dealing with the
Vampire horde last minute I'll be out of
the city I'll have a lot of money and
I'll have food all the things you need
to survive he quickly interviews the
city's residence to get the full story
finding out from this beard guy that the
powerful church has denied
responsibility for these attacks they
think killing Dracula's wife was
justified in the right thing to do and
that God approved it and they are
blaming everyone but themselves the town
is divided and has begun pointing
fingers at everyone Trevor going down a
city street runs into an old man a man
that will change everything Trevor
overhears these Church guards blaming
the old man for Dracula's attacks they
think he's being controlled by the devil
and they don't trust his new ways of
thinking they prepare to brutally kill
him when Trevor suddenly stops them
cutting off this guy's finger gouging
out this man's eyeball nasty he rescues
the old man with ease he then introduces
himself to Trevor and says that he's a
part of a peaceful tribe of magicians
they've come to the this town to offer
help to the citizens and are now being
blamed by the church for Dracula's
attacks Trevor offers to walk the old
man back to his safe house where he
meets the rest of his tribe group and
they fill him in on the situation and
why they're really here according to an
ancient legend a legendary Soldier is
sleeping beneath the city once he wakes
up he'll come back and save everyone and
this tribe wants to find him and wake
him up Trevor thinks they're crazy and
they revealed to him that one of their
members went looking for the ancient
Soldier last night but is now missing
and by the way it's the old man's
grandchild Trevor feels bad for these
people and decides to help them out but
his price for helping them is that they
get out of town before Dracula's demon
Army comes back tonight so you're
telling me we're now going to be looking
for the wallachian version of Captain
America at this point I'm not going to
trust one word that comes out of this
group of aot dressed wannabes this tribe
is a group of Scholars called the
speakers they basically memorize the
oral history of this country for fun and
help people blood they're too nice
because while they may not look it and
they don't these guys are overpowered as
hell they are knowledgeable
practitioners of the magical art just
like vampires but these guys fight for
good which is really nice this means
that I would bring a few of these dudes
down with me when we're looking for this
guy's granddaughter because while I may
be the strongest sexiest vampire Hunter
alive we are severely outmatched right
now Trevor finds the secret entrance and
heads underneath the castle noticing
advanced technology heated pipes and
electricity he discovers these Frozen
corpses and runs into this Cyclops
lasting at him Trevor quickly takes
cover using both his Whip and his sword
he swiftly kills the beast but that's
when the Frozen spell of the corpses
wear off and he finds the old man's
granddaughter this girl saifa he takes
her back to reunite with the old man but
tells Trevor that the monsters were
guarding something down there and she
thinks it's the legendary Soldier Trevor
tells them that he did see advanced
technology while they were down there
and suspects that they may have reached
Dracula's Lair Trevor leaves the group
and tells them to leave while they can
and runs into this church dude who stops
him in his tracks telling him the most
powerful man of the area wants to see
him the bishop of Gresham there Trevor
confronts him about blaming the demon
events on the speaker the bishop thinks
the hordes of monsters came due to the
Public's lack of faith in God Trevor is
incredulous and the bishop tells Trevor
that the speakers make the perfect
scapegoats this man arranged Dracula's
wife's death and his batshit shocking
Trevor to the Bone he tells Trevor that
other cities have already fallen and
these demons will help put the fear of
God back into the public making this
bishop the most powerful man in willekia
he tells Trevor that he'll spare him and
that the innocent speakers will be
sacrificed tonight by Sundown this guy's
insane this bishop is scarier than a
regular enemy he is not acting this way
out of what must be done he thinks that
he's right that his current and past
actions are justifiable and approved by
God this guy's a wacko his thugs are
wackos everyone here is nuts this
spaceship is so clearly not doing the
will of God right now he killed
Dracula's wife so easily despite being a
man of God and that's why he's able to
act swiftly and all the crazy stuff that
he is doing he's not like the Joker
instigating [__] for fun while this guy
actually thinks he's the good guy in
this story and that everyone else is
wrong this means we're not going to be
able to debate the evil out of him and
realign his moral compass he doesn't
have one the only way to stop him is by
killing him outright if I'm Trevor and I
did just kill a stone laser blasting
Cyclops by myself I think I can take on
a bunch of thugs with my Whip and short
sword I will be able to kill the bishop
and find my way out and lose his thugs
in the city and then sneak out of
greshit through the sewers Trevor
ignores The Bishop's warning and runs
back to the speakers telling old man
what's headed their way if they don't
leave now stubborn these fools think
that they can help this city and refuse
to leave make it a speech about trying
to save Humanity blah blah blah they
managed to convince Trevor to be a sexy
hero coming up with a plan he hides the
speakers down below where he found cypha
and Sundown finally arrives the demon
Monsters And The Bishop's people both
prepare for blood to be spilled The
Bishop's goons head to the speaker's
Hideout but find only Trevor there they
demand for him to hand over the speakers
but instead he makes a break for it and
runs away doing some really sweet
parkour moves and slows them down but he
accidentally bumps into one eye guy from
earlier and they duke it out meanwhile
the bishop remains hit in his church
knowing that the demons can't enter the
house of God but that's when something
horrifying easily opens the doors this
blue Fang to demon the bishop is shock
that tells us that they shouldn't be
allowed in here a place of worship the
demon smiles and tells them that he's
the direct cause behind the demon
outbreak without him they would not be
here they tell him that his actions have
made God puke God doesn't love him
anymore but they do unable to do
anything the terrified Bishop waits for
blue fangs to lay a kiss on him brutally
dying in the process back outside Trevor
runs for his life out of breath he gets
cornered and is about to die when Cypher
does some magic to protect him and helps
him Escape but Trevor calls out to The
Bishop's second in command this guy and
makes the public finally realize that
the church is to blame for the demon
attack he watches the citizens quickly
Slaughter the church guy just as the
demons break into the city Trevor
quickly gives the town's folks some
Battle Tactics to follow and prepares
them for the bloody fight Cypher helps
him out and slows down the monsters
working together they manage to
desperately take out out all of the
Demons for now suddenly the ground
erupts and Trevor and scypha both fall
deep underground it's strange they come
across countless booby traps as they try
to navigate the dangerous area okay what
just happened this just keeps getting
weirder and weirder these guys have just
stumbled onto another entrance deeper
into the underbelly of this city than
they were last time and clearly not only
is this place a death trap a death trap
on the verge of falling apart the minute
we fell down here we should have tried
to find a way to get right back up from
where we came from I just saw cypha use
a magic to slow our fall so hopefully
she's got some magic juice to get us
back up and out straight up because
remembering from the last time they came
in here Trevor noticed advanced
technology that he's never seen before
1. whatever built this place knew that
Intruders were probably going to try to
find it so instead of defenses and two
it set up its defenses in a place that
is so old that the ground is subtly
breaking off sending off a domino effect
that caused the entirety of this weak
structure to go to [__] because
everything that we were standing on top
of came tumbling down considering that
all the metal here is either iron or
steel that means that whatever set this
place up did so a century ago but the
fact that its booby traps are still
active and that there is electricity and
that there's heat this makes me think of
one of two possibilities one the
original creators have died and whatever
is down here is moved in and set up
defenses or two we're dealing with
something that is so old and so powerful
that the only likely explanation is that
we just stumbled into a vampire Den
barely making it out alive that's when
they noticed this strange Hall and
accidentally discover a hidden secret
Trevor steps on a center that causes
this coffin to open up waking up this
ice cold perfect creature as it begins
to float up in the air Cypher thinks
this guy's the sleeping Soldier but
Trevor knows this man ain't no hero but
it's just another six-pack stud AKA The
Love Child of Fabio and Edward Cullen a
vampire Trevor thinks this is Dracula
himself Trevor takes out his web and
tries to attack him but he blocks it and
the vampire uses his powers to surprise
him clashing swords until Trevor knocks
him into cojones and this damn demon
feels absolutely nothing down there and
tells him to have some class the fine
thing goes to a stalemate with both of
them prepared to take out the other one
however Cipher them breaks up the fight
the mysterious creature then smiles and
says he thinks they're worthy of his
plan and introduces himself as Dracula's
son Alucard Alucard reveals to the two
that he tried to stop his father from
releasing his demon Army but he was
defeated sleeping beneath this city for
the last year he says that he's finally
healed all up and that he's ready to
fight his father once again Trevor
doesn't trust him but Alucard reveals
that the sleeping Soldier prophecy
stated that he would be awakened by a
magician and a hunter proving that these
two were meant to find him finally
convinced the three team up but Trevor
realizes that teaming up with Dracula's
son is not enough and thinks that this
group isn't ready yet he tells them that
if they really want to kill Dracula
they'll need to head to his old family
Mansion which is home to generations and
generations of vampire Hunter knowledge
hidden deep under his foundations and
will hopefully still have the tools and
weapons they need to stop Dracula once
and for all meanwhile Dracula starts to
get impatient his demon attack at the
city of greshit didn't work so he calls
his vampire generals around the world to
meet him at his castle these are the
world's most horrifying serial killer
and Dracula tells them that these two
human assistants of his blue eye guy and
tattoo face here will be in charge of
his plans from now on and that everybody
here must listen to them or else the
vampire generals are shocked and begin
to think that their vampire lord has
started to lose his mind and grow weak
okay this is terrifying right now the
world is about to get royally screwed
but what's even more scary is that even
the Predators at the top of the food
chain here aren't even working well
together anymore and that means
everything can get even worse because
the way these people are going about
their plants it's not methodical it's
not planned out it's just simply
destruction all over to even the
untrained eye it's obvious at this point
that Dracula here has lost his marbles
trigly didn't act like the leader they
knew in the past with what he did on
full display right in front of them no
vampire General would ever be okay with
humans giving them orders he should not
have strong-armed his generals into
obeying him this is going to cause him
problems down the road what he should
have done was to use logic and make
these generals think things through if I
was Dracula I would have told them that
as vampires we can't think exactly like
humans because we're not human but in
order to eliminate the filth that are
humans we have to think like filth by
using these two humans to eliminate
their own race Dracula could have made
the argument that having humans kill
humans would actually display their
power even more and if the vampires are
truly going to take over the entire
human world we will need to learn to
work together even if it is with a small
group of humans because even though the
human race is pathetic and weak without
them the vampires can't survive taking
over the human world would require
coordination and teamwork which means
that Dracula should have worked on
inspiring the group to think of them all
as a team rather than a hierarchy
Dracula should have inspired this group
to work together to contribute to our
bottom line rather than just having
Dracula forces will onto his generals
it's never worked well throughout
history and is not going to work well
here either and on top of that Dracula
isn't even taking into account that his
vampires have come from all over the
world each of them have their own
different style and how they get [__]
done for example Redbeard here is
clearly a vampire Viking meaning that
Dracula could have probably predicted
that his problem-solving style would be
to use brute force over critical
thinking Dracula could have used this to
his Advantage rather than just going
against him straight away because in
doing this Dracula just made himself an
enemy and on top of that he just caused
friction within his group of generals
and while Dracula may be the most
cunning and powerful thing on earth it's
clear that even his dead heart can feel
things because he is so deep in his
Fields right now it's disgusting him
giving in to his grief will be the
biggest factor that will probably
contribute to his downfall hint hint
just then a pale blonde General walks in
late to the party and the one person who
is going to ruin everybody's dinner
plans her name is carmilla this carmilla
asks Dracula what all the others are
thinking why are the vampires going to
war over his dead wife Furious Dracula
forces her to speak to him in private
where she tells him that he needs to be
careful with how he treats his generals
or else they may soon turn on him but he
dismisses her and tells her that he has
everything under control but that was
his biggest mistake meanwhile Trevor's
group sets up camp on their way to his
family mansion a dollar card tells him
that his father is punishing Humanity
for the death of his wife and a la carte
even tells them that he's even seen
books of the plans that Dracula has for
the world once he makes Humanity go
extinct and that the books are made from
the dried skins of the people he hates
most but just then they hear sounds in
the distance and they realize that a
patrol from Dracula's demon Army has
found them okay is it just me but
doesn't this bear demon with the big
totally look like a dude cosplaying as
one of those plague doctors and also
despite having a happy vampire fighting
with a long sword on our team while it
is great this a la carte guy played it
all wrong if I was them I would have
expected trouble to find us I mean we
did kind of cancel out their invasion of
greshit we should have been more careful
about how we chose to set up camp out in
the wild because while saifa may have
been a cute nobody and a la carte was
presumed to be in hiding for centuries
and no one knew where he was exactly
Trevor being the world's greatest
vampire Hunter and human means that it
would have been obvious that we would
have been hunted down due to our
reputation alone and the fact that
humans live less than 100 years means
the Dracula would have known that the
Belmont family still probably had a
chance of being alive and therefore he
himself was under Threat by default and
look at this hey they were acting like
they were camping in Canada no cover no
nothing why would you ever do that they
didn't even bother to light the fire
deeper into the ground by doing this the
light from the Flames would not have
been as visible from a distance in fact
there was no point in even lighting a
fire at all think about it we got a la
carte the happy vampire over here which
means he can easily handle the weather
endless being a big sexy strong man with
a whip that we should have been able to
suck up the cold as well and Scythe on
the other hand she's a freaking wizard
I'm pretty sure she could have turned on
some magical heat warmers and kept
herself warm point is they did
everything wrong covering the fire at
the first time of danger was pointless
as well because if you can now hear the
enemy they're already too close for
comfort and they know where you are by
putting out the light they've just
alerted the bad guys that they know that
they are there if I was them I would
lift the fire on I would have quickly
retreated into the forest behind them
that would have allowed me to blend in
with the cover and provide me with an
environment to better hide myself from
their View and if we also notice a lot
of these demons have long weapons like
scythes and possess Wings to fly meaning
they're likely built for a battle in
open terrain AKA old school medieval
style type of fighting meaning that many
of the Demons would likely not be as
effective in fighting in close quarter
combat out in the forest once the enemy
is within the forest and unable to see
us clearly that I would have used the
cover of the woods to do the following I
would have ordered Alucard to attack
them in the front while I would then use
Trevor to flank them coming up from
behind and pinning the demons in place
and then use Cipher with her long-range
spells to provide support from a
distance and also have a wider view of
the battle overall and be able to
provide support to either one of them
should the situation arise and also we
cannot let any of them go free the worst
thing that can happen is if we let even
one of these demon bastards Escape
they've not only found our location but
they've also found out our identities I
mean it's not that hard to put two and
two together to quickly prepare for
battle a la carte quickly draws his
sword and takes the first swing or a
first stab and uses his super speed to
Shish Kebab the crap out of these two
demons and Trevor and saifa sort of
pigeon it's amazing after the bloodbath
one demon escapes and heads back to
Dracula's castle a little while later
reading the corpse of the Demons the
vampire counts is informed that Trevor
and Dracula's son were spotted near the
city of Gresham and they now think that
Alucard and Trevor are working together
against them tattoo guy tells him that
he suspects that they're headed to
Trevor's old family mansion and carmilla
freaks out at this news she states that
though the Belmont estate is destroyed
she's terrified that they'll somehow
find a hidden treasure Trove that'll
give them access to the most powerful
vampire killing tools in the world
tattoo guy tells Dracula that they must
be stopped before that happens but the
other vampire generals disagree with him
and they tell Dracula that they
shouldn't worry about one pathetic
vampire Hunter carmilla disagrees with
this tattoo guy tells them all that they
should stay focused on their plans to
wipe out humanity and they all looked
Dracula he shocks them all by telling
him that he doesn't know what to do and
needs more time to think not eager to
die anytime soon carmilla later goes to
talk to Blue Eye Guy about Dracula not
being able to make up his mind and
acting out of anger over his dead wife
she thinks he's leading them all down to
a path of self-destruction nervous blue
eye can't help but agree and also thinks
that his beloved Master Dracula isn't
the powerful man he used to be she tries
to convince him to create a magical Army
to go looking for Trevor at his family's
match and she tells him that if he
really wants to help Dracula he needs to
convince the vampire lord to attack this
city called brayla because if they
secure this city they'll be able to take
over the rest of the country in no time
blue eye guy hesitates to help her and
thinks that they should think about this
but she tells him that Dracula isn't
thinking clearly and it's up to them to
help him win before Dracula destroys the
entire vampire race okay this is a
sticky situation that I'm not sure I
want to be in this blue eye guy is a
human who has basically been mistreated
by Humanity all of his life and now he
hates them for it but the scary thing is
is that while he may have allegiances to
the vampire race most of these
bloodsuckers don't trust him for [__]
and will easily kill him if given the
chance that means if I was him I'd think
twice before making any moves one good
thing about Dracula's ways is that he's
predictable and he thinks everyone will
listen to him his ego makes him
complacent whereas carmilla clearly has
greater Ambitions than just being a
general and is shall we say unhappy with
her current position this makes her
unpredictable and currently the greater
threat between the two since we can't
predict Her Moves however the one thing
that has kept Dracula from ruling the
entire world has been his need to keep
humans alive as a food source and also
to honor his wife Dracula is way more
powerful than people realize at taking
over the power structure he set in place
could change everything if I was blue
eye guy I would first use my Powers as a
forge Master to my full advantage these
guys are basically necromancers that are
able to bring back corpses from the dead
to fight for them this is why knowing
the risks involved and to keep carmilla
satisfied and not kill me I would agree
to work with her for now or secretly
build my very own personal Undead Army
giving me at the very least an
overwhelming offensive advantage in case
she screws me over or if Dracula finds
out about my betrayal this may not be
the best option but it's the best one
out of a series of shitty options
because at this point we're stuck
between a rock and a hard place so what
you gonna do you gotta figure out a way
to survive the naipa good intention Blue
Egg guy wants what's best for his master
and so he agrees to help her in secret
that was his biggest mistake meanwhile
Trevor's group finally reaches his old
family mansion and discover a secret
entrance into the basement using magic
they open the door and head down below
discovering generations of vampire
killing resources founded by Trevor's
ancestors something down here will tell
them how to kill Dracula and the three
get to work on figuring out how to save
the world and reach Dracula's castle
before it's too late back at Dracula's
castle one of his General's Red Beard
guy here asks him a question that all
the generals have been thinking he asks
him where will the vampires get their
blood if Humanity goes extinct Dracula
tells him that he has blood supplies and
fresh animals stored in the castle and
red beer guy says that animal blood
gives him the poops gross and red beer
guy notices something he gets concerned
and doesn't trust Dracula anymore and
thinks that he just wants to make
Humanity go extinct out of grief and
anger Dracula gets pissed off and tells
him to get the hell out walking out Red
Beard guy bumps into carmilla and tells
her that Dracula is on a suicide mission
to join his dead wife and is trying to
take everyone down with him he also
mentions that he noticed something about
Dracula just now and it's huge telling
her that he thinks the vampire lord
hasn't fed on any humans in a while
because he's weak it's strange a light
bulb then goes off in Carmela's head and
she realizes something and knocks
Redbeard guy down the stairs she tells
him to focus because they need to act
immediately Dracula is weak and
distracted she tells Redbeard that they
need to now convince him to teleport the
castle right now to the city of brayla
he asks why she is so interested in that
City and she mysteriously tells him that
that city is where she'll be free having
once been a vampire slave to a crazy old
man carmilla is tired of crazy old men
running the world and she tells Redbeard
that Dracula's pathetic human wife has
made him soft and reveals to him her
horrifying plans to betray Dracula and
both of them work on figuring out how to
kill the ruler of the night and you
don't want to get bit by no sexy vampire
then like comment let us know what you
liked and of course don't like don't
forget to check out the holiday playlist
down below